rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message practice who you want to be over
to you Michelle Obama you have to
practice who you want to be you know you
don't wake up one morning and you're
suddenly who you think you want to be
you have to put some energy into it so
if you want to be an honest person you
have to be an honest person every day
even starting at three and four and five
right if you're going to be a hard work
or hard work doesn't just appear you
have to practice hard work you have to
practice effort you know and and I also
encourage them and try to help them
understand that good things don't come
easy now with that effort that's where
you grow that's where growth is some of
the best times in my life when I've
grown it's when I've done something hard
when I've overcome a fear each you don't
realize that when you're doing it but
when you come out on the other side you
realize wow I've really stepped up I
don't think most people are able to
practice who they want to be because
they have no idea who they want to be
and if you don't have that clear vision
of who you want to be the kind of person
that you imagine yourself being the
ideal version of yourself if you don't
have that clear picture then you can't
practice it you don't have the
self-awareness I think that's where most
people fall down is they know they're
unhappy with where they are and they see
other people being happy but they don't
know how to be happy themselves they
don't know how to be themselves they
don't know what that looks like and so
that's why I wrote your one word the
self-awareness to figure out what is
your most important core value and what
are the three things that breaks down
into your credo
it's your roadmap for life and allows
you to practice being who you want to be
so
example for me my when were his believe
that breaks down into my credo into
passion doing work that you love into
impact having a big impact the work that
I do matters and then into self
confidence which is what most people
think believe is the self confidence to
believe in yourself that gives me my
roadmap for how to wake up every day I
want to do work that makes me feel
belief so if I take impact as an example
that's part of my credo that's part of
what belief looks like I need to be
doing work that is having an impact for
me to practice who I want to be so today
is a great example I'm showing up I'm
making videos or making a lot of big
videos for the channel my sincere hope
is that this video and all the ones I
make today are gonna have a big impact
it's gonna be seen by thousands hundreds
of thousands and millions of people that
to me feels like it's impactful if I'm
spending my time in the minutiae of
something and it's not leaving tiny
results if I'm spending my time having a
meeting with someone who's disrespecting
my time if I'm spending my time just
twiddling my thumbs and browse around on
Facebook or doing something that is not
high-impact
then I'm gonna be feeling like a letting
myself down I'm not practicing who I
want to be and I think for most people
you know when you're doing the thing
that you don't want to be doing you know
that spending time on Facebook or
Twitter in your thumbs or doing
something where somebody's disrespecting
you you know that's not the life that
you want but you don't know how to
actually practice the life that you do
want you don't know what that looks like
you don't understand what your core
value is you don't know what you stand
for and until you understand what you
stand for then you don't know what you
stand against and you can't practice
being who you want to be and so the
methodology I use is the book your one
word whether you use my methodology or
someone else's having a self-awareness
to know who you are as a human being
gives you the confidence to move forward
in life it allows you to stop living
somebody else's version of your life it
allows you to say no and to push back
when people are encroaching on your
values it allows you to go off and build
that thing that you want to build and so
I highly highly highly highly encourage
you to yes practice every day who you
want to be but first you got to figure
out
who you want to be and do the
self-awareness exercises to get that
plan in action
so the question of the day today is I'm
curious what is the one thing that you
need to practice a little bit more every
day for you to practice being who you
want to be what is that one habit that
one trait that you need to practice
every single day just a little bit
harder let me know leaving the comments
below I'm really curious to see what you
have to say I also want to give a quick
shout out to Maria Rivera Ramirez thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word and posting that
awesome review about it I really
appreciate the support and I'm so glad
that you enjoyed the book so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot event
spresso
[Music]
I remain I'm uninterested in that topic
Tom which one whether the relationship
between gift and practice no I want to
trust it in natural gifts and I know
they exist and I know there's such a
thing as talented as neither that but I
just feel like so and so what right
because there are people and I always
think of year about scoff in Iowa sake
of Derrick Coleman yes I remember
chatting with a guy who worked for the
Sixers and he said you have to
understand the Derrick Coleman was the
most gifted man ever to set foot on a
basketball court he said I you I get you
know you've heard a nut a million other
names
nobody was as good as Derrick and like
who has heard today who thinks who puts
Derrick Coleman up there in the pantheon
no one he didn't want to work he had bad
habits he had a bad attitude I mean so
what give me somebody who wants to go to
practice in the morning and he wants to
try in games and I want to celebrate him
you look for that thing that that that
moves you I don't know what it is
I like repetition I there's a saying
goes rapid repetition repetition keeps
me green yeah I love that saying that
position keeps me green keeps me green
become fresh because the idea that we do
performance is over and over again you
would say well doesn't that get boring
or stale but no it's in the repetition
that the creation comes that the
expression comes because I'll give you
an example I was doing Richard once not
particularly well and this show is going
on and we couldn't get this court seen
with a lot of people in it I didn't
understand what I was doing in the scene
so we would call rehearsals I would
rehearse it and stuff and we would talk
about it think about it you know like
all
this kind of work with people together
and trying to figure out something in
the 85th performance of Richard I had
done my 85th entrance
I knew the court see I understood it I I
was there I could play but not in 84 not
maybe four I was I might have been
getting closer than realize it yeah I
gave up the ghost I guess I just gave it
up and said oh screw it it's not gonna
happen and I'll just keep going on and I
found it
people who've asked me that over the
years you know how do i collab or how do
i bend the ball and yeah it's something
that just happened it's not something
that I thought okay I want to bend the
ball better than anyone else so I'm
gonna kick the ball with this certain
way I just worked on my striking of the
ball I just practiced every day it's
something that I've done from a very
young age you know even after every
training session you know I take balls
on on my own and just go and kick and
and and try and find new ways of getting
the ball in the net without anyone
touching it and you know I've been I've
been lucky enough to have done that over
the years with with the wire kick the
ball and I know that it's a unique style
and I know I know it's a unique style
just because my back hurts a little bit
more than than it did when I was 15
years old but no I you know it's
something I practice of course you know
it's one thing I tell kids and and
unless you practice you're never gonna
you know get better at something if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details